Мін'юст має намір з нового року
оприлюднити реєстр неплатників аліментів.
До того ж, нещодавно Верховна Рада
посилила відповідальність для недобросовісних аліментників.
А як у Німеччині змушують платити гроші на дітей?
Після розлучення той із батьків, з ким залишаються діти,
має право на аліменти.
Про їхній розмір чоловік і жінка можуть
домовитися за згодою сторін
Якщо ж аліменти - предмет суперечок,
то їхній розмір визначають на основі
так званої "Дюссельдорфської таблиці"
Згідно з нею, мінімальний розмір аліментів
на місяць у 2018 році становитиме:
Чим більший заробіток - тим вищі аліменти
Загалом десять груп за рівнем доходів
Якщо ж аліментник не виконує своїх фінансових зобов’язань
на захист дитини стає держава
Потерпіла сторона має звернутися зі скаргою
до управління у справах молоді - у відділ опіки
Чиновники спершу надсилають ввічливого листа із закликом виплатити аліменти
В останньому абзаці - застереження:
Якщо заклик буде проігнорований, відомство подасть у суд
на недобросовісного аліментника
Зазвичай це спрацьовує: судитися з державою не хочуть
Якщо ж і це не допоможе, держава виплачує так званий аванс по виплаті аліментів
Він менший, ніж суми в "Дюссельдорфській таблиці" на 2018 рік:
Суму всіх виплачених авансів держава ставить недобросовісному аліментнику в борг
який той зобов'язаний згодом погасити або відпрацювати
Інакше, приміром, не зможе отримати жодних позик